[Musik]
guten tag bald ist er 100 tage im amt
der churer bischof joseph maria bommer
gilt als brückenbauer der die
zerrütteten verhältnis im bistum wieder
kippen soll der ehemalige arzt
bezeichnet sich selbst gerne als mini
portionen eines bischofs versteht
trainieren als einen akt der
nächstenliebe und wenn keinesfalls als
exzellenz angesprochen werden
guten tag wir finden noch mehr raus in
dieser halben stunde guten taten sehen
sie hier
bischof joseph maria name josef kommt
mehrfach in ihrem amt vor
in josef jahr wurden sie geweiht und die
am josefstag im josefsaal jetzt richtig
zusammen was bedeutet ihnen dieser name
das also präsent ist gut dass der name
mit dem ich getauft wurde
zusammen mit maria und für mich josef
war ein mensch und mann der kaum
gesprochen hat in der bibel findet
schickten die aufsteiger von ihm
sie meinen jetzt dein vater von jesus
jesus aber durch hat gewarnt
jedes mal dass das eher dran war dass
gott von ihm erwartete hat er richtig
daran tun das schätze ich sehr
ich sage immer auch dass das es wahrlich
nicht dass ich schönes erzähle oder die
linke weg fort habe schon da
ich halte die zeitabschnitte schon zu
handeln und das ist viel schwieriger
es gibt ja auch noch an anderen josef in
der bibel im ersten alten testament ja
und die wird liga-chef rat auch im
grunde gerannt was uns das handeln steht
bei ihnen im vordergrund was spricht
denn sonst bleiben wir bei der theorie
der theorie kommen wir noch was spricht
denn jetzt in der theorie gegen die
exzellenz weshalb wollen sie nicht als
exzellenz angesprochen hatten
ich hoffe dass spielt ein exzellentes
gespräch habe
während für mich ich spreche gerne zum
beispiel vor ein instrument in wain
ein hervorragender centrix sport
sportler aber sonst ich habe deshalb bin
ich eine mini portion alles andere
chance als schritt auf allen gut sie
sind ja als einzelkind in katalonien
aufgewachsen möchte ihre mutter war
katalanien ihr vater jura cia
interessanterweise sind das doch zwei
solisten bitte zwei separatisten genau
über hat das irgendwie was bei ihnen
ausgelöst oder irgendwie sie eignet man
wahrscheinlich wenig eine gefährliche
sprünge mischung geworden sind sie
glaube ich ja also ich habe ich habe
mühe mit traditionellen angespielten
vorstellungen abzufinden nicht ich frage
mich immer gesagt man könnte es nicht
anders tun wenn es möglich etwas
innovatives zu erreichen muss man sich
einfügen wahrscheinlich sind die
separatistischen gilt die solide
explosives eine auf eine explosive
amtszeit vorbereitet ich fühle mich
wünschen dass sein ist prosieben eine
sportive anzeigt des heils nicht denken
sie ein bisschen an das ereignis von
pfingsten nicht plötzlich dieses diese
bleiben
dieses getöse um dann kann man diese
feuerzungen und daneben das spart eine
spur nicht so begannen die kirche diese
mischung die sie jetzt gerade
angesprochen aber auch die explosive
mischung die sieht man ja auch in ihrem
bischofsring oder können sie erklären
was ich genau dazu dass sie nicht durch
block iv für mich etwas besonderes weil
erstens wenn einer zum bischof ernannt
wird oder es gibt solche die hatten
anwerben die beginnen sich gedanken zu
machen was für einen drink fertig tragen
was sie einen bischofsstab ich hatte
keine zeit für linke zu bestimmen ich
wollte eben am tag des heiligen josef
geweiht zu werben und deswegen gab es
keine große zeit
scharfe forderungen zu treffen und
weiter wir bekamen einen drink das schon
bereit
in chur waren aktiv aber ich hatte vor
die zwei ringe meinen eltern die ich
schon schrieb habe als menschen die
durch höhen und tiefen doch treu
zueinander geblieben sind wollte ich mit
beiden erringen
neben den bischof zu städten herstellen
zu lassen
als zeichen meiner träume zum bistum
fragen zu den menschen in diesem bistum
ich hoffe dass gott mir hilft diesen
menschen treu zu bleiben auch wenn ich
habe manchmal wieder mich zurückziehen
möchte den kader wieder dann ja doch
wieder geld am schalter bis zum schluss
diesen bistum dienen
sie sagen wenn sie mir haben was
bereitet ihnen denn mir ja dat wicht die
aufgaben die wahrzunehmen sind die
probleme die entstehen
es ist die marken guter junger mann
dachte ich man kann endgültige lösung
für die indigene etwas treffen oder
finden inzwischen habe ich gesehen dass
das leben ein provisorium ist nicht wenn
ich dran bin etwas anzugehen
zu entscheidungen kommen neue
situationen manchmal denke ich erst
wieder gut wie früher du mit einem
patienten im spital schön
sie war sehr lange spital seien circa 36
ja und das ist eigentlich hdmi ich mich
ganz ok und ich finde das natürlich band
sie haben gesagt das leben sei ein
provisorium und das hilft helfen quasi
tauch ist das leben irgendwann oder ist
der tod nicht mehr das provisorium uhr
endet das provisorium irgendwann mit dem
druck den das provisorium aber nicht das
leben
dann beginnt das leben leben das produkt
ist hier auch werben
aber ist so schön zu wissen dass das wir
unterwegs sind zu einem ziel das uns
ähnlich nicht in deutschland wirft dass
jene schüler die bibel
gerade fein liebe die uns nicht verrät
eine wahrheit die keine lügen hält ein
licht das nie ausgeht
dieses buch ist in uns drinnen nicht und
so wissen
nach ein paar tagen geht auf wunsch welt
und dann kommt diese fülle die wieder
erstehen
diese perspektive wechsel der ja im
christentum quasi drin liegt nämlich
eine andere perspektive auf den toden
damit auch auf das leben erscheint mir
doch auch in filmen gegeben wenn man
filme schaut und sie schauen ja auch
sehr oder haben sehr gerne film geschaut
wie schaut es bleibt mehr aber ihr vater
hat ja die sich damit ist richtig sagt
die filmstudios von metro-goldwyn-mayer
geleitet wo man ganz oft in barcelona
auch da im kino drei viermal pro woche
ja und gab es da viel mit da wo sie auch
fanden dieser film ändert wirklich meine
perspektive hatten hat ihre perspektive
auf das leben verändert kann meine
passion lebensperspektive geprägt viele
ich kann ihnen den namen nicht sagen
weil ich die namen von den filmen er
wohl vergessen aber den inhalten nicht
die inhalte nicht und es ist immer
dasselbe nicht vielmehr etwas das nie
zutiefst ergreift anschaulich
dargestellt wie zb nämlich die schönheit
von menschlichen beziehungen auch zu
krisen hindurch aber zu sehen dass eine
partnerschaft ein freund eine
gemeinschaft die ich tragen
aschau diese diese sehnsucht auch mit
menschen zu tun zu haben die
geborgenheit eine stütze gleich
gesinnung ein austausch ermöglichen
das komme natürlich unzählige varianten
in den filmen nicht
sogar ein paar räuber die gemeinschaft
was stellen wollen aber dieses
zusammenhalten und zusammen etwas
gewagtes unternehmen nun das ist ja das
kommt den krieg widmen vor
liebesfilme unzähligen aber diese immer
diese in der mensch braucht beziehung
der mensch ist für die beziehungen
geschaffen
gott die sowieso eine unendliche nie zu
ende gehende beziehung nicht diese drei
personen in gott wie die sich lieben die
sich auf staus in die der schon der
abstand vater kommt und dass das ist die
menschen auch vorhanden nicht wir sind
nicht eine einsame insel wir brauchen
beziehungen und das kommen neben das
kommt in unzähligen varianten in den
filmen vor sind sie aus diesem grund das
zeigt er auch eine gewisse liebe für den
menschen überhaupt sind sie aus diesem
grund denn auch arzt chirurg geworden
oder was würden sie sagen war der grund
dafür gestiegen
es gibt so ein jahr comics über
beispielhafte leben mindestens damals
aus team war und meine eltern haben mir
immer wieder solche comics geschenkt und
es gibt dankbar bin ich selbst
eigentlich haben zum beispiel arbeit
schweiz das leben von auto schweiz ein
universalgelehrter muss man dazu
eigentlich ja ich bin arzt hin wie kunz
länder
damian
apostel von den lepra kranken wiederum
nicht oder thomas modos vision sieht
großkanzler von england dieser mann fiel
eine wahrheit entsteht aber sehr klug
bis zuletzt versucht die situation zu
meistern aber am schluss bekennt farbe
diese dies bekomme ich gerade diese
sehnsucht ja was kann man machen im
leben am besten den menschen nahe zu
sein und für die menschen da zu sein und
deswegen habe ich medizin studiert und
dann haben sie irgendwann auch wenn ich
das richtig recherchiert habe rosa maria
escrivá kennengelernt ist das richtig
haben richtig richtig geht und da haben
sie also ist der gründer muss man sagen
dass das oberste und der wurde ja auch
2002 heiliggesprochen muss man gleich
dazu noch sagen
haben sie wegen ihm sich der theologie
sind zugewandt oder war das ich angehen
mit wahl vorgeschlagen
er hat das foul hatte nie daran gedacht
also ich kann mit karma denn darauf gut
ich ein bisschen aus schrauben nicht ich
als mittels schülerin barcelona noch
hatte ich ein paar kollegen freunde die
ihn einen bildungschip
ein hund ausging genommen sie haben mich
immer wieder eingeladen kommen doch auch
mit ist gut es gibt so glaubens
vorträgen dort finden statt aber ich
hatte nie großes interesse noch mehr
sichtbare schimmlig zurückhaltend in
diesem modus aber da hat er kurz
nachfragen also sind sie nicht religiös
aufgewachsen dass sie da diese
zurückhaltend normal religiösen mein
vater war ein stich habe gläubige meine
mutter mehr unwahrscheinlich liebe
verliert unser mutter geprägt aber nicht
besonders und mein held genau was sie
hörten
meine kollegin carmen mit der buße zu
tun hatte war und was lieber nicht und
so weiter deswegen habe ich es selber
angezeigt nicht nicht geworden nicht
hinzugehen und dann wurde ich eingeladen
zu einem gottesdienst mit scriba das war
ja sexy und die predigt hält dort
gehalten hat hat mich gepackt nicht ich
habe gesagt jetzt dieses fahrrad hat
mich erwischt nichts so habe ich gedacht
weil die botschaft war eben für mich
eine eine eine eindeckung nicht die
wirtschaft die welt und alles was in der
welt gibt entfernt und nicht von gott
sondern wirklichkeit nicht also die
arbeit der spaß die beziehung denn das
leiden die freuden die arbeit die
familie alles ist ein ort der
gottesbegegnung nicht später diese
brille kurve tituliert die welt
leidenschaftlich lieben und das spiel
mit erinnerung nicht dass ich
denn was ich tat in dem was ich vorhatte
zum beispiel medizin zu studieren nun
aus arzt zu wirken
auch sehr nahe bei gott sein konnte da
wird durch die beziehung zu den menschen
so dass das material ist vergänglich ist
dies nicht ein hindernis um gott zu
finden sondern im gegenteil dass das ist
was nicht verstehen wie es heute deshalb
finden sie sich dort auch einem aufgang
dann bin ich mitglied der chaussee
gewerbe und arbeit und ich habe dann was
ich wollte mir jetzt in der studie
am schluss des studiums habe ich
begonnen als assistenzarzt in der kg zu
erweitern weil ich eben kilo die machen
wollte und dann irgendwann kam noch der
gründe aus
damals lebte noch und fragte mich josef
könntest du dich eventuell vorstellen
im spital aufzuhören und nach rom zu
kommen und theorie zu studieren und das
angebot dann hab ich gedacht da vinci es
meinen warum nicht ist vielleicht kann
ich auch dort für die menschen nützlich
sein
aber hätte man sich doch noch nachfragen
sie haben gesagt die leute haben sie
auch gewarnt davon und ich habe mich
eben das auch gefragt hat dass sie nicht
beunruhigt dass man dem opus dei auch
die nähe zur franco diktatur immer
wieder nachgesagt hat immerhin gab es ja
doch einige mitglieder die da in der
regierung wichtige posten inne aber
gleichzeitig gab dessen mitglieder die
gegen franco im exil warten nicht
das habe ich auch fahren nicht als das
im opus betreffen politische meinung hat
kann und darf jeder scheint also dass
ihre haltung ist dazu es gab einfach
beides es war nicht eine direkte
unterstützung auch so ergiebig habe das
gefühl gehabt auch mit meiner express
lieben nonkonformistischen art habe ich
meinen ort im busch das will ich eine
schwierigkeit aber weshalb hat man sie
denn davor gewarnt dort hinzugehen weil
ich glaube dass wir vielleicht heute
noch ein weibliches gibt um meine eltern
hatten nur ein paar nachrichten oder
transport zu
gehört die ski dann durch nicht auch die
realität kennengelernt haben also die
klischees sind ja die wurden natürlich
jetzt auch wieder thematisiert als sie
eben bischof wurden zum beispiel die
konservative tät und wie undurchsichtig
dass der opus dei sei und so weiter ich
will mir gar nicht über diese klischees
reden sie haben genug oft darüber auch
gesprochen aber eines kleines dieser
klischees möchte ich doch noch kurz
kolportiertes dass mit diesem das
eigentlich nicht nur ein klischee
sondern das ist ja tatsächlich so mit
den genitalien und gürtel denn man trägt
am oberschenkel jahre schmerz machen
soll sie tragen den offenbar nicht oder
nicht mehr merken sie erzählen weshalb
war weil ich glaube dass inzwischen
nicht nur so viel gelernt hat dass das
nicht unbedingt förderlich ist nicht
meine sache busch übungen haben bei den
jahrhunderten viele in den klöstern aber
eben auch thomas muster und sind zum
beispiel nicht tragbar aus hemd und
schönen bleibe raus aufs kanzler vom
england nicht wie gesagt es ist eine
ganze zeit zur kirche habe ich glaube
dass allmählich
es ist schön dass wieder eine lebendige
entwicklung wahrnehmen nicht man hat
eingesehen dass es geht um die harmonie
zu erreichen zwischen geist leidenschaft
sinnlichkeit vernunft und verwies juni
muss man denken das gleichgewicht
reichen und manchmal auch etwas zu
verzichten oder etwas tun was
überwindung kostet
das verbrechen von diesen nicht aber das
wie viele möglichkeiten ohne spülung
was haben sie heute schon verzichtet um
zu verzichten
das verzichten fühlen sie sich unzählige
kleinigkeiten des alltags pünktlich
irgendwo zu erscheinen nicht darauf
vielleicht mann ist begeistert nicht
aber man ist minister an emails zu haben
worten und anschließend habe ich jetzt
stand die sternstunden dann stehe ich
auf und später als ob diese
konzentration diese diese sich
beherrschen
vor allem bei herrchen wenn es darum
geht für die menschen dazu scheinen
nochmals nicht wenn ich vielleicht nicht
so große lust habe zu antworten und doch
ein hamburger wenn ich wenn ich versuche
zu lächeln auch verbrauch beträgt wien
von bestimmten situationen dass das in
viele übungen ab und auch nicht wird sie
sagen ja auch eine form der kasteiung
sei eben das fitnesscenter und da hat
sie daneben aber die richtige
darstellung maxime ich esse die sf
rundschau hat sie da begleitet verstehen
[Musik]
bischof joseph asket und kraftprotz
seine muskeln werte brauchen denn sein
neues zuhause ist hier im punkt des
bischöflichen schlosses in chur
also das ist der alte teil des schlosses
mit dem ich nicht so viel anfangen kann
mit all diesen strukturellen und
verzieht und gehen von verwaltungen und
soweit nicht dass das das hat keinen
sinn aus dem geschäft ist geschäft war
nicht attraktiv es nicht vorbei aber das
dann wird sie auch nicht hier wohnen
wohnen im sinne dass die bücher von
google besitzen vorher fertig werden
werden beweglicher sich vereinigt wird
und der weg nicht der bischof führt zur
schlosskapelle ideal für latein messe
liebhaber kein ort für joseph bonneau
priester zelebrieren hier mit dem rücken
zu den gläubigen nicht die heutige
lithologie der renovierte moderne teil
des schlosses
hier fühlt sich wohl
das ist mein wille das ist aber klein
fordert bischof wieso ich bin eine mini
portion aber auch wenn ich viel mehr
verkehr wirtschaft in einer modernen
welt von selbst kasteien zu sprechen das
liegt oft suspekt und gleichzeitig wenn
man an früher denkt dann war es eher
suspekt wenn man ein bischof im
kraftzentrum gesehen sind wie kamen sie
denn dazu ja vor
30 35 jahre kt rückenbeschwerden und man
habe mit den folien die muskulatur zu
kräftigen und so habe ich begonnen und
dann wird fahndung gemacht dass das
einen festen neben
spaß machen können diese muskeln
brauchen sie wahrscheinlich auch in
ihrem amt wenn man bedenkt die römisch
katholische kirche ist doch in einem
etwas maroden zustand in gewissen in
gewisser hinsicht
kürzlich ist ja auch kardinal marx hat
seinen rücktritt in deutschland
angeboten wurde nicht angenommen
wenn man jetzt das thema sexuellen
missbrauch bedenkt sie waren ja da sehr
nahe dran sie waren sekretär des
fachgremiums sexuelle übergriffe im
kirchenumfeld der bischofskonferenz in
der schweiz dann bin ich immer noch weil
dann die bischöfe haben gemeint du hast
es werde in 18 jahre getan
das könntest du dir schon innerhalb der
bischofskonferenz übernehmen also ich
habe habe ich das noch mal wird am
morgen dürfen ja gut umso besser sein
ich wollte sie fragen was hat es denn
mit ihnen als mensch gemacht so nahe
dran zu sein
das kam mir kleiner gemacht
bescheidene haben wir gezeigt dass es
ist nicht richtig ist mit klarheit und
zu mit gewissheiten nicht gewissheit in
frieden sondern man wird bescheiden und
demütig
gerade im brief des papstes am
kapitalmarkt zu sagen dass er den krieg
nicht dann nimmt wunderbare papst
geschrieben ich fahre sehr mutig von ihm
und ich bin sehr dankbar weil ich habe
ich muss sagen schon vorher das gesagt
nicht die institution muss in folge zum
stehen
wir brauchen nicht den guten ruf der
richtige ton zu schonen aber zu
verteidigen das es wird um die menschen
müssen alles für die opfer tun nicht
viele institutionen und das hat der
papst jetzt schwarz auf weiß geschrieben
nicht und deswegen habe ich gelernt in
diesen jahren das dass ich viel weniger
die institution berücksichtigen und
selbst auch mein prestige sondern das
tun was die menschen brauchen um dieses
umdenken ist flug von all diesen jahren
der schongang smitten auffallen wenn sie
sagen man muss an die menschen denken
dann nehme ich ein konkretes beispiel
aus dem bistum chur
es gibt es da die in den 60er jahren ein
kind aus sexuellem missbrauch bekommen
hat von einem tk sie hat bis vor
zumindest vor ihrer amtszeit keine
einsicht in die akten bekommen wird sie
jetzt unter ihnen akteneinsicht bekommen
für mich besteht kein problem dass sie
einzig bekommt aber natürlich die frage
ist was erwartet sie was erwartet sie
von diesem akteneinsicht vielleicht ist
sie in deutschland sehr wenige akten
vorhanden sind jetzt zuerst mal
natürlich dass die offenheit bestehen
dass im kreis gar einlösen und dann
klarheit was mit anderen was mit anderen
jugendlichen wissen sie ich habe schon
gesagt nicht glaube beim interview mit
dem beobachter ich wäre alles öffnen
damit habe ich kein problem nochmals
bald wie natürlichkeit transparenter
bescheidenen der papst hat sogar gesagt
nicht nur die einzelnen menschen in der
kirche sondern die kirche als schalke
sollte jede schuld bekennen
das ist geschafft und was glauben sie
wie die kirche darstellt wenn man
endlich mal dieser freie aufgearbeitet
hat frei und wirtschaft gibt es die
kirche noch ist das nicht ein
abgebranntes haus nach allen diesen
veröffentlichungen dann sind sie
abgebrannt
weshalb sollte ich abgebrannt sein weil
wir sind deswegen habe ich doch eine
überraschung
die kirche nicht die institution sondern
die kirche sind diese wunderbare
begeistert
menschen mit visionen die um jesus
christus stand entschieden
das heißt die institution an sich mit
priester sakramentenspendung all das was
dazu gehört dass es gar nicht so wichtig
wichtig ist was was gott in den herzen
der menschen hervorruft das ist ein
statement aber dass das führt mich an
einer anderen punkt neue in bezug auf
kirchenaustritte haben sie auch eine
aussage gemacht die ich zugegebenermaßen
etwas kritisch fand sie haben gesagt
gespann die partie
aus demselben grund was sie gerade
ausgeführt haben haben sie gesagt im
kirchenaustritte sorgen sie nicht und um
vollständig zu sein sie haben auch noch
gesagt die menschen seien von grund auf
religion religiös sind durch leben heißt
verbinden die beziehung zwischen gott
und mensch bleibt bis zuletzt bestehen
das kann auch mal genau aber wenn sie
sagen dass die kirchenaustritte sie
nicht sorgen dann sagen sie auch etwas
diesen menschen gegenüber die eben
symbolisch und demonstrativ aus der
kirche ausgetreten sind wie etwa doris
strahm 2018
weil sie dachten sie bewegt sich nicht
diese kirche die leute fühlen sich unter
umständen nicht ernst genommen
ich bin bis jetzt begonnen sie die
absicht ist eine institution zu
verlassen aber nicht die sehnsucht aus
meinem herzen trägt nicht um eine im
grunde wie man das haus als zeichen der
rebellion als protest tut betont man
noch mehr bisher und das anliegen im
herzen ist nicht dieses anliegen eine
situation die die echte bau billiger
seien schuld zu die suchenden sind die
die wirklich glaubenden eine eine glaube
die sich nicht in frage stellt ich
glaube diesen worten hat ist ein
pubertärer gläubiger sind die suchenden
die zweifel haben die immer ein
fragezeichen
viele geheimnisse des lebens
offensichtlich wir waren nicht leben das
habe ich auch inzwischen leben können
nicht zuletzt dank darf ich noch etwas
schreiben sie sind jetzt eben 100 tage
wald im amt was war das schwierigste bis
jetzt das schwierigste ja ganz klar die
zeit begrenzt es fällt mir nicht um den
unfall das anzupacken um zu bearbeiten
zu tun was eigentlich nötig werde und
dass das berichten die ihren tag mit dem
konfrontiert wie schaffe ich es wie geht
es ihnen damit sie wissen was papst
johannes 23 den gesagt hat dass er nach
fünf tagen amtszeit nicht er wurde
gewählt als papst und zelte werden fünf
tagen konnte ich nicht schlafen
ich habe alle probleme sorgen der kirche
und nach fünf tagen in der nacht eine
stimmige sagt giovanni veränderte truppe
richtig so er hasst diese nach caputh
schwarz ist diese stimme schon bei ihnen
angekommen noch nicht
ich schlafe weniger gut aus aber ich
hoffe dass diese stimme kann man
angesichts unseres team schließlich das
vertrauen dass das entscheidende nicht
von uns kommt sondern von gott drei
dimensioniert so auch die show nicht
aber dann trage ich trotzdem noch eine
andere stimme hier in studios
schlussfrage sie werden mit vielen
erwartungen konkreten auch in bezug auf
die segnung von homosexuellen oder die
gleichstellung von frauen konfrontiert
wahrhaftigen wir da hoffen was darf man
erwarten dass ich mich einsetzen werden
möchte um will um den richtigen weg auch
in diesen fragen zu finden
aber das ist nicht einfach
das ist nicht einfach es ist nicht
einfach weil einige warten pauschalen
worten und das ist auch dass es wieder
nicht menschengerecht weil ihre menschen
seien nicht ihre mensch befindet sich in
eine andere situation es geht nicht die
homosexuellen besondere es gibt ich habe
aber es gibt ein anspruch von
homosexuellen auf segnung das ist schon
ein pauschal anspruch und deswegen darf
ich ausschließen anspruch nicht nicht
pauschal reagieren sondern diese die
konkreten menschen dieser sorge wünschen
ems nehmen und sie persönlich gut
kennenlernen und jede situation
umständen sehr ernst nehmen dann nehme
ich das als schlusswort und bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei herrn frau spielen
nächste woche erwartet sie ein
japanischer morgen mit tee und shinto
auf dem monte veritabler zuerst geht es
um die pflicht sie hat wahrlich keinen
guten ruf klingt nach müll sortieren und
abwasch tatsächlich sind wir aber darauf
angewiesen dass menschen ihre pflicht
tun in privaten beziehungen die
innerhalb des staates richard david
precht redet uns deshalb ins gewissen
jetzt in der sternstunde philosophie
[Musik]